Well, don't worry, I
've already mastered the art of shutting out other people's hearts I
'm tired of hearing the voices of my heart I'm sick of it That's why I always wear earplugs
Sealed  What is this ability
? I
can hear the explosion
.
I don't want to feel bad about telepathy
anymore.
Oh yeah, but it was just an occult research group that fell short of my expectations
Thanks to that
, I no longer harbored the faint hope that my comrades might be somewhere.
I don't intend
to be used If you think that's the end of it, I don't think you need to cooperate If you're
really not interested at all, what do you want to say?
It
's a part of me that I can't throw away, and if there's
someone who wants it,
it might be fun to accept it for a little while
.
I'm in trouble even if
you do, so I'll give you special cooperation just this time